a
[Música]
ahora sí
el 90% de los 2.6 millones de afganos
refugiados en el mundo viven en dos
países pakistán e irán que acoge a 800
mil de ellos pero no significa que estos
sean los únicos ciudadanos de esta
nacionalidad que vivan en irán que dejó
de dar el estatus de refugiados hace 20
años cuando cayeron los talibanes más de
2 millones de afganos viven como
migrantes económicos y cruzan
ilegalmente al país esto es una un cruce
transitorio van y vienen constantemente
buscando una mejor vida y otros buscan
pasar a turquía un país que se ha
convertido también en favorito de los
inmigrantes y refugiados afganos en los
últimos años y que han reforzado las
fronteras en los últimos meses tal como
lo ha hecho pakistán que ha dicho que no
recibirá refugiados más allá de aquellos
que tengan papeles en regla en pakistán
e irán que también no recogerá a estos
refugiados pero si bien ha creado
campamentos y algunos hospitales
temporales en algunos puntos de la
frontera para dar apoyo a quienes lo
necesiten aunque dice que serían
refugiados temporales y que tendrán que
regresar al país apenas la situación se
estabilice
un hipotético éxodo masivo de afganos
tras la toma de kabul por parte de los
talibán ha puesto en alerta a los países
de la región que temen una nueva oleada
de migrantes turquía que ya es el país
que más refugiados acoge de todo el
mundo y ha advertido sobre todo a las
autoridades europeas que no se va a
convertir en un almacén de refugiados
por su parte la unión europea asegura
que esta crisis no va a ser la misma que
la guerra de siria y que no se va a
producir una nueva oleada de emigrantes
como la que hubo en 2015 por otro lado
ha sugerido a los países de la región
sobre todo a pakistán y turquía la
posibilidad de establecer una especie de
cooperación regional para gestionar esta
ola migratoria por otro lado grecia ha
empezado a construir una nueva valla en
su frontera con turquía y turquía está
haciendo lo mismo en su frontera con
irán una bahía llena de torres de
vigilancia cámaras de seguridad y
sensores para impedir el paso de estos
migrantes
el presidente y bando que confirmó que
colombia era un refugio temporal a
algunos afganos que huyen de su país
mientras hacen un registro para su
traslado migratorio a eeuu el mandatario
resaltó que washington va a asumir los
costos de la atención de estas personas
el anuncio de duke se produce casi a la
misma vez que el portavoz del
departamento de estado en el price
explicase en una rueda de prensa que
varias naciones están dispuestas a
amparar a afganos en riesgo entre los
países latinoamericanos anunciados
además de colombia se encuentra méxico
chile y costa rica colombia es el
principal país de acogida de la
migración de la vecina venezuela en los
últimos años ha recibido más de 1,7
millones de venezolanos y el gobierno
duque se propone regularizar los
mediante un estatuto temporal de
protección
[Música]